papa mon papa madame bonjour tout le
monde je suis en pleine forme
aujourd'hui et je sens bon je ne me suis
pas fumer avec de l'eau de cologne à la
fraise c'est un parfum comme à refaire
ma tante adélaïde
ouais je m'en suis ni sur la tête un peu
dans le dos et voilà j'ai envie que tout
le monde soit bien aujourd'hui dans
l'île aux enfants
je vais d'abord allé voir julie parce
qu'elle rit tout le temps bonjour
mademoiselle bonjour casimir très occupé
tu as vu comme je suis bon c'est très
beau mais pas du thunnus enfants mon
parfum quoi ma tante adélaïde m'a offert
une autre cologne donc je sais rien non
mais pourtant j'ai mis presque toute la
bouteille écoute casimir tu es adorable
oui j'ai beaucoup travail tu vois alors
je t'en supplie le soin termine bon roma
tant pis je te laisse alors je vais
aller voir françois pas d'âme pas
bonjour françois comment vas tu moi je
vais très bien oui bonjour casimir que
s'il te plaît pas ce moelleux banos qui
est sur la chaise à côté du doigt voilà
merci hein tu as senti comme je sens bon
maintenant et adelaïde m'a offert une
autre toile est parfumé à la fraise des
bois pour l'expulsion des immigrés alors
un deux trois blancs 1 2 3 4 5 j'ai
l'impression souhaiteraient occuper un
oui oui c'est ça mais ouais je me mets
ballon rouge à bombay trouve ça va je
reviendrai tout à l'heure c'est ça je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont tous les deux
mais alors j'aimerais un facteur
j'espère que lui au moins aura un petit
peu de temps pour moi bonjour casimir je
suis désolé je suis très pressé je n'ai
rien pour toi
julie bonjour
quatre paquets julie merci je
l'attendais mais ils sont fous de
travailler comme ça enfin haut mais j'ai
l'impression d'être complètement inutile
bonjour bon casimir
bonjour monsieur disent non je suis très
content de pouvoir on vous avez rendez
vous avec une personne de qualité
ah non pas du tout est quoi le bien que
je le regrette forme il alors vous allez
pouvoir parler avec moi je m'ennuie mais
c'est totalement impossible casimir
pourra refuser de parler avec moi le pas
du tout avec un très grand plaisir vous
parlerez philosophie psychologie pas
tout le monde est prononcée voudrais
simplement que l'on parle de moi à oui
je vois et je le regrette casimir mais
j'ai rendez vous avec mon coiffeur
particulier pour me faire couper les
cheveux
c'est un front alors mais qu'est ce que
je vais devenir mais tu peux aller jouer
avec françois mais non françois travail
julie travail
j'ai l'impression que je ne sers à rien
ce n'est pas grave
casimir tu devrais travailler toi aussi
te rendre utile ah oui c'est une idée
mais mais mais comment au je te fais
confiance à casimir aller à tout à
l'heure mon bon casimir bon attendez
monsieur du snob
j'ai une idée oui qui attire j'ai une
idée combien vous prend votre coiffeur
pour vous couper les cheveux 100 francs
pour quoi bon reggae moi je voulais coup
pour 1 60 franc je suis d'accord mais
pour 50 francs à pour 50 francs vous
aurez une coupe mais pas de shampooing a
beau et bien 55 francs à 50 sec ce ne
sera pas la même coupe
vous comprenez le le prix dépend du
travail
il est en outre qu'à vos cheveux sont
sont très sales abîmé cassé il ya
beaucoup de travail pourront alors je
suis d'accord pour 60 francs casimir
c'est entendu
marché conclu la queue ne bougeait pas
je vais chercher ma malle magique
ne t'inquiète pas je ne vous mens
bonjour monsieur christophe bonjour mon
ami mais oui je vous dois passer je vous
chercher partout
j'avais une lettre à vous remettre et
comme je ne vous ai pas trouvé je les
laisse à la poste ah mais c'est très
ennuyée ça on va écouter je dois revenir
ici apporter un taquet à françois oui
alors si vous êtes encore là tout à
l'heure moi je vous apporterez votre
lettre à mon cher emile nous n'est pas
d'être sens et que j'apprécie de jour en
jour un peu plus merci bien mais celle
du stop
moi aussi vous savez je vous apprécie
bien tout à l'heure c'est l'heure voilà
la main voilà monsieur du snab bien nous
allons pouvoir commencer
très bien je pose mon chapeau et makan
je vous en prie je vous allez passer
cette blouse
vous ne vous sentirez pas cas merci
infiniment
voilà voilà ça va ça va bien je vous
donne un tabouret
voilà merci à attendait il y a un un
appui tête qui va avec un appui tête
voilà bon prenez également le peigne
merci voilà les ciseaux les ciseaux les
six ont amené casimir ce n'est pas une
paire de ciseaux mais c'est vraiment
excusez moi je me suis trompé
c'est le sécateur avec lequel je coupe
mes abdos attendez que je vais le
prouver
ah mais ça non plus non ça je sais vous
ça c'est pour les cocistes demong lobby
brugat abandon d voila voila a très bien
mais didot casimir je me pose une
question tout à coup
oui est-ce que tu s'est coupé les
cheveux mais voyons monsieur 10 nov je
me les coupe à moi même tu n'as pas de
cheveux ah oui c'est vrai non mais je
les coupe à toute ma famille c'est mon
père qui m'a appris alors ah bon nous
voilà rassurés
soyez tranquille bon je vais vous nous
arranger tout ça et voilà le
chef-d'oeuvre terminer monsieur du snob
vous allez être très content
monsieur du snav mes idéaux
city non mais quelle horreur chauffe
mais on tue mais c'est affreux
que s'est il passé si toi tu m'as fait
ça ouais et alors et c'est monsieur de
snobs fait que la demande et ouais alors
il voulait être chaud non mais comme
monsieur du snop est très snob
j'ai pensé qu'une coupe un peu original
lui plairait mais il va être sur yon
faut pas le réveiller trop vite on vous
croyez à écouter jeu j'ai quelque chose
pour arranger ça voilà une perruque site
ouais ça lui ira très bien je t'assure
qu'il sera très bon temps avec eux mais
que se passe-t-il ici mais c'est
monsieur d'islam que lui est il arrivé
il est malade c'est casimir tonné
françois voilà votre paquet est rédigé
cette lettre pour monsieur du snob -
c'est sûrement un rendez vous regardez
l'enveloppent alors s'il est un rendez
vous avec une personnalité importante
quelle catastrophe pardonnez moi mes
chers amis je m'étais endormi mais
qu'avez-vous à me regarder comme ça
rien rien dit
govou que j'ai rêvé que j'étais choses
admirables extraordinaire à quasiment
c'est un peu déchets de très très bien
chez du snob
voilà votre lettre à mr simon dolet
voyons cela
au ladakh
c'est là qu'on teste du ballet qui me
donnent rendez-vous quelle chance je
prends lui me faire admirer avec ma
nouvelle coiffure très bien bien bien je
voulais m'amuser bien attendez attendez
merci beaucoup merci merci merci mille
jeunes hommes voilà casimir t 60 francs
alors du franc 20 francs 30 francs dans
mon bonbon 40 francs 50 francs soit 36
monsieur du snav
voilà mes amis bientôt elle pour boire
vous voyez comment ma coiffure lui plaît
beaucoup
oui il est craint content et il le sera
beaucoup moins quand il s'apercevra
qu'il a une perruque
il va être sur ie je voudrais pas être
là à ce moment là bonjour tout le monde
bonjour je viens de croiser monsieur du
snob
j'en ris encore figurez-vous qu'il s'est
fait teindre les cheveux en v et al
aryane drôle c'est casimir qui lui a mis
une perruque
après lui avoir coupé tous ses cheveux
et quand monsieur 10,9 à découvrir ça
ils piquera une colère terrible pour sûr
mais le plus tard sera le mieux
mais qu'il était derrière mais si la
perruque de monsieur du snob misère
j'ai dû l'accrocher quand je les
croisais sur le chemin
m
[Musique]